i had been in ukraine since mid-january
and there's all this talk about an
imminent war but what was interesting at
the time is whether you spoke to a
soldier on the front line in the dumbass
region or you spoke to just an ordinary
ukrainian everyone was brushing off the
idea of a russian invasion and some
people were actually quite
upset at the west especially at
washington for being so alarmist
[Music]
when i first got there at the start of
march we headed to the second largest
city kharkiv now what was most striking
about that city was just the lack of
people out on the streets many people
were sheltering in metro stations there
used to be nuclear bunkers during the
soviet era but also the constant sound
of artillery what i remember as soon as
i crossed the border to ukraine from
poland is like getting on a van
with women returning
from poland to see their husbands or
sons who were not able to leave the
country when the war started mostly
because all men of fighting age could
not leave the country we went to a
maternity hospital
where a newborn baby maya
had not had the sun on her face she had
been born underground in this maternity
hospital and her mother said that she
hoped for a world or a ukraine that was
peaceful we were at a clinic that treats
post-traumatic stress disorder we spoke
to one man andre and he told us how it
was affecting him how he was getting
flashbacks how
at times when he closed his eyes things
seemed to get faster and faster and it
struck me that at the end of the war
we're going to be talking thousands if
not tens of thousands of people who will
suffer from post-traumatic stress
because
of the war in ukraine russia took
everyone by surprise by coming from the
north and advancing towards cave when
the missiles were flying when cities
were being hit you could not hear one
voice at that point
being pro-russia and i always wondered
that that mean that the support that
russia
had in that part of the country has
diminished or simply people were too
afraid to talk we can't ignore the fact
that in the east of the country those
areas that russia controls and even some
of those areas that russia doesn't
control yet
there are people there that are
pro-russian that are not pro-ukrainian
they feel disenfranchised they feel more
of affinity towards russia than they do
ukraine for now the ukrainian government
is requesting more weapons to try to go
on the offensive winter is coming and
that's also going to play a key role
during this war but what everyone's
certain here is that this is going to be
a very long war but then you have a
bigger picture and that's the rivalry
between moscow and washington moscow and
nato the expansion of nato a lot of
people told me on the ground he said the
problem we have is that we have become
the battleground between these two
powers and yes the west is helping us
yes without the western weapons we
couldn't advance an inch or we couldn't
regain any kind of territory we couldn't
protect our cities but unless that
bigger problem is solved then it will be
impossible to bring some sort of peace
to ukraine